i got 10 o'clock
hi david how are you laura
nope it's not live well
lara's ignoring me how are you
good sorry about that
how are you laura very good
i was married like yeah
oh laura's ignoring me
david i can't protect you from laura so
you're on your own
all right and now you can begin to
represent the members okay
we're now going to open the public uh
sessions for the criminal justice public
safety committee as the chair of the
house criminal justice and public safety
committee i find that due to the state
of emergency
declared by the governor as a result of
the cover 19
pandemic in accordance with the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a committee orientation meeting
please note that there is no physical
location for the members of the public
to observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting
however in accordance with the executive
order i am confirming that all members
of the committee
and select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through zoom electronic meeting platform
the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in the meeting
by the zoom platform by telephone all
necessary access
information has been made available in
the house calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general core website
this notice uh the notice for this
meeting
complies with house rule and rsa 91-a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call
271-3600 or email
hcs leg.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
i want to first introduce the staff that
are on the meeting assisting us
brad greenland
and brad thank you for setting this up
today and assisting us
and please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote and let's start the
meeting by taking a roll call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there's anyone
in the room
with you during this meeting which is
requiring the right to know
representative bert
i am here and uh my dog is also here
annie
representative hopper i am here and my
grandson
may come in and out of the room because
i am in
interfering with his trip to the kitchen
representative green yeah
representative wallace
representative wallace you're on mute
representative testerman
representative true here
uh my wife is in the house and so is my
dog hunter
representative pratt
yeah along with my dog
representative rhodes here my husband
may be here
within a half an hour walking in the
door
representative harris gathright
i'm present um i am in the house i'm in
this room alone but
my son and my granddaughter is here
representative panda pantalookus
i'm here but i'm alone
representative o'hearn
representative burnett here
my wife is in the house
representative muse i'm here and along
in the room
representative newman
i am here and my wife representative sue
newman
is in the house and maybe in the room
intimately
representative bolden
hi i'm president um in the house is my
husband andrew
my daughter sophia um a cute dog named
max
and a cute dog named jack and a very fat
cat representative conley
representative conley
representative klein knight
i'm president with another bunch batch
of puppies
and i've got my sister in another room
representative bradley i'm here
and my daughters are in another room
mr chair representative
wallace representative testerman
representative o'hearn
and representative conley have not
have not wallace's representative
wallace is on i think you get cut
off during the roll call okay
you just responded okay
representative wallace you're here i am
present at my office
in merrimack at my shop couple of
employees are in the building
and jennifer just for roll call purposes
you've got to
call myself in the representative the
vice chair as well
chairman abbas present
and vice chairman welch
i'm here all right
all right so
thank you everyone one of the one of the
things i want to do before we start
uh this is just the preference of the
chair is that i
before our committee meetings i would
like to us to as a committee
recite the pledge of allegiance uh so
anyone wishes to participate we can do
that
uh as a precaution remember we're all on
camera i tell people you know when you
stand up
you know just do it as you see fit but
just remember that so
we'll recite the pledge so i ask they
want to unmute themselves
amen
so before we get started on discussing
how this this year is going to go and i
know there's a lot of uncertainty
and i know a lot of you can have a lot
of questions i i think it's important
that we
all go around the room and introduce
each other
uh and i'm just going to call on one
person each person separately i'll start
with myself
just to explain my background you know
any skills that you have any
professional
background you can explain your district
really introduce yourself to everyone
especially the people who don't
don't know each other my name is daryl
abbas it's now my second term
i uh i hail from rockingham county
district 8 which is
salem new hampshire i moved to salem
when i was three years old
i was originally born in houston texas
but i
i still live in my hometown today i am
married i have a two and a half year old
son my wife is also expecting
my wife and i'm expecting our second
child at the end of may
so i asked this committee to uh embrace
that impact
i i may uh i may be off the radar for a
week or two when that happens so
bear with me if you guys are wondering
it is a girl
i uh my professional background i went
to suffolk university
uh i graduated in 2006 i then went to
immediately went to suffolk university
law school i
graduated in 2009 i've been practicing
law for over 10 years now
and i'm a partner at a law firm and
the overwhelming majority of my work is
out of state which is a really good
thing
i prefer not to litigation can be very
uh
combative so it's actually somewhat of a
belief not to deal with that
in-state but i will say that
when i ran i actually when i decided to
run for a state rep this was the
committee i wanted to serve on so it's a
tremendous honor to sit on this
committee and to sit as the chairman of
the committee
i felt that with my background and
experience that i really could
contribute
to a lot of laws and bills and stuff
that comes before the community and the
people who served with me last year know
that i'll even offer advice on bills
that i don't support
i still offer ex you know hey this is
how this might play out
and i do that because i think it's good
uh public policy to really try to put
the best bill forward whether
i'm gonna vote for or not it's a
different story and that's
something that i always made a point i
also am the type that i
i understand that we're all members of
different political parties
but at the same time you know i
really i vote with the constitution
platform aside i feel that that's
really what you know guides me on what
i'm trying to do and
and this sometimes bills that i it was a
bill last year that i uh last term that
i really liked and i voted against it
because it was unconstitutional and just
it's unfortunate but it was what it was
so
that's me and anyone has any questions
everyone knows i'm very approachable
so we'll just go around the room uh next
the vice chairman david welch
oh good morning everyone this is my uh
18th room i've been around for a while
my background is i worked for at t in
north hanover mass
for 31 years i retired
in 1993 and i devoted full-time
to the legislature
i've had a good run this is likely to be
my last
term and i've been recently married
this is four years ago i was widowed
and i kind of give up but then i met a
girl that i grew up with
and she was she was a recent widow we
got together and everything was good
so that's one of the reasons why this is
likely to be my last term
but
what is that
i've been uh first elected chairman
of god how long ago is the public
protection
veterans affairs committee in 1996
then speaker donna scitec
created the criminal justice and public
safety committee and i was his first
chairman
and i've been chairman for many years of
this committee
um i've been vice chairman of this
committee and i've been
a member of this committee i don't bring
any particular professional experience
to the subject matter but
he has a nay i've been around
for a long time i'm willing to help
anyone
on on anything here the committee
has gone from it used to be a very
friendly committee
sometimes it's not as friendly as it
used to be uh
i hope i will be friendly there in the
next two years
and uh i'm looking forward to it take
care
that's it thank you david and just for
the roll call purposes i see that
uh representative testerman has joined
us
hi can you hear me yes
i you know we'll put you on the hot seat
since you were late
we're going around the room allowing it
uh just having everyone introduce
themselves and
explain their background or whatever it
is they want to explain about themselves
just you know does everyone get to know
each other so representative testament
you're up
i'm sorry for being late uh the uh zoom
was not working well
uh but anyway i i thank you for uh
letting me be on the committee actually
uh this is my third term um
i i'm actually an engineer i
worked for uh about 20 years with vae
but before that i was in the
air force i flew b-52's 300 combat
missions we won 11's
worked on the b2 for six years and
some other activity then came here to
new hampshire
i'm not a native of new hampshire i've
been here since 93
when we my first assignment in the air
force was to new england
and we fell in love with the area and so
just as soon as we could we got back
i'm very conservative and
i'm fairly open on what i have to say so
with that
let's let's enjoy the year
thank you representative testament uh
representative
bert
thank you mr chairman um i do have
comcast
in goffstown which is not good so i'm on
my hot spot
right now but that's even in and out all
the time so i do apologize if i check
out a couple times
um for anybody that doesn't know me i am
john burt
i have six grandchildren i live here
with um
you know they all live in vermont uh so
i try to see them as often as i can
so zoom and skype is pretty kind of cool
keep me in touch with them
um i live here with my wife i met her in
uh we were married in 2006 and between
the two of us we have four children
um i have a hobby chicken coop
my aunt you know my dog annie uh is very
close to me um
you know she's with me all the time now
for
state house uh i'm in my sixth term
four terms on criminal justice
i have um you know my passion
is the second amendment um
i was very happy last year when i sued
the speaker of the house
and one at the supreme court level
you know so i'm hoping that i get my day
in superior court but we'll see
sadly both sides are trying to get rid
of it
other than that um you know i just
believe in uh
doing what your heart says to do and
that's what i'll do in my committee
and uh so i'm glad to be on criminal
justice and uh thank you mr chairman
thank you representative burt um
representative
gathering
um this is my third yes
hi this is dick marston
hey go
this is my third term i served on
criminal justice 2012
2014 because this is the second
consecutive
term so um i retired from verizon after
35 years of service
back in 2008.
um i have five children and
12 grandchildren uh most of them are
here
most of them were born here i migrated
here in
79 from philadelphia pennsylvania at a
young age
most of my life i've been right here in
nashua i've been in this particular home
42 years um
very active in the community um
particularly around civil rights
and human rights um
i am a former hillsborough county
executive committee member i serve on
the board of aldermen here in nashua
serving my second or third term one any
other
um i co-chair um
national community conversation on race
and justice without chief of police
and a lot of the activities down at this
end of
of the city of the state so um
i enjoy criminal justice i believe that
i've worked pretty well with most people
on the team um
i believe in respecting others opinions
in a decent way i am a no-nonsense
person
and i don't believe in people being rude
thank you
thank you representative gathright uh
representative pantalakis and before she
starts everyone
probably already knows this she is the
dean of the house and that's a
it's been an honor to have her on the
committee and respect those stripes is
what i
recommend everyone do
or you're on uh you're on mute
okay now
i'm serving my 22nd term
in the house representative i was once a
chairman and a vice chairman of criminal
justice
i'm the mother of seven children 17
grandchildren
and 16 great-grandchildren what i did
before i came to the house
i forgotten it so long ago
thank you
thank you representative pandolakis uh
representative boardney
oh yes um i
live in keene have have done so for the
last 34 years
i grew up in tennessee and i have
uh masters of mechanical engineering and
software engineering
i'm retired this is my fourth term
in the legislature second term in
criminal justice
thank you representative board name
representative hopper
hey folks i'm representative gary harper
i was first elected in 2000
i my trade is a tool maker slash
machinist um
i ran because i i know a bit about
history and
and i love the phrase that all is
necessary for evil to succeed
is good men do nothing so i decided to
run even though i was working full-time
because if you don't fight back you get
nothing
you have you don't have really much of a
right to say anything
um so i served in 2000 i served on the
fish and game committee for quite a few
years
in 2010 i became uh or
basically i'm dick moston how are you
hi dick it was nice to talk to you
that's too fun okay so anyway back to
back to reality so um
in 2011 i became uh chair of fish and
game by the end of the year
i aggravated the speaker too much and i
was booted off of that
and in 2011 at by the end of the year i
i went over to uh the judiciary
committee
i served there for until till this term
i decided to come over to criminal
justice because
well you know it's mainly because chris
truth sat in back of me for the last two
years
and i and i and i wanted to hang out
with him basically
and john burt but john burt is really
upsetting me because he's
not really socially distancing because i
live in where and he lives in ghost town
i really think
for the purposes of these meetings he
should have to go to bedford but that's
my thought
thanks thank you representative hopper
mr chairman mr chairman
representative dick marston just called
me and he said that he believes he is he
wasn't recognized on the roll call
and then also he doesn't think we can
see him which i am looking right at him
um so he just wants to make sure that he
is in the committee and that he has been
recognized
on the roll call being present
uh representative marston i one week i
can see you
i don't i hope everyone else can and uh
representative rhodes was he recognized
on the roll call
mr chairman the only person i have
representative o'hearn
i i wasn't sure who who john just
mentioned wasn't here i i missed the
name
um i have representative o'hearn and
representative
conley is absent
okay uh representative marston you are
uh
recorded as being present and with that
being said the floor is yours
at the introduction thank you thank you
uh
mr chairman uh i was on criminal justice
in my last term which was four years ago
i'm a returning state rep
uh i enjoyed serving on criminal justice
and specifically has to be on it again
according to the the list from the
clerk's office
my name is mentioned just above jennifer
rhodes
or right after kevin pratt so hopefully
they'll put me in the list for future
roll calls
and i'm always willing to participate in
any parts of the committee that
i'm asked to do it was a pleasure to get
back into the state house one more time
this is my third term i was first on
election law
and criminal justice and again criminal
justice
i thank you for recognizing me at this
point and hopefully i'll be counted as
present for this
orientation meeting thank you very much
thank you representative muse
uh hi there my name is david muse i am
the representative of ward 5 in
portsmouth
which includes most of our downtown
and waterfront area i
have employment experience in new
hampshire
my first job out of college i was a
reporter at wmur
i also worked in corporate
communications at uh
bae systems for almost four years
i was sanders associates back then
and was a partner in a benefits
uh consulting firm called aeon hewitt
for 25 years this is my second
stint on the criminal justice and public
safety committee i'm
i'm happy to be back and i'm looking
forward to working with everybody
sorry thank you representatives
representative newman
hi i'm ray newman i'm this is my second
term
i represent hillsboro 29 that's ward 2
in nashua
graduated providence college
i came to new hampshire in 1981.
i'm married have three
three grown children
and six grandchildren
um before i came to be a state rep
i was a helicopter pilot and after
that i after about five years of doing
that i became a contr
air traffic controller then eventually
an air traffic control
supervisor and when i retired
from that i did research for the mitre
corporation
on air traffic problem detection
they've been working on that for about
20 years i hope they get figure it out
one of these days
and i'm glad to be back on
criminal justice
thank you representative representative
green
yes my name is dennis green i represent
rockingham
13 which includes hampstead and kingston
i've lived in hampstead for 28 years now
and married 54 years i have two grown
children a daughter and a son
uh i was brought up in the military uh
i had a chance to go on the police
departments years ago
and because of the hours and the days uh
i chose the automotive field and i went
into the automotive field
and became different phases of
management
i went to general motors college for
and i've had my own repair shop and
when i retired i decided to get
involved in politics and that's how i
get here and
this is my fourth term in fourth term on
criminal justice
it's great to be here
thank you representative green
representative wallace
good morning everyone this is
representative scott wallace
from danville new hampshire which is
rockingham county district 12.
my third term in the house third term on
criminal justice and public safety
committee member of the rockingham
county executive committee
chairman of the rockingham county jail
and executive subcommittee
i grew up in hampstead been
the town in danville now for 27 years i
went to pinkerton academy over in derry
class of 83
unh until 87 small business owner
in auto repair uh real estate
development and rental
and i'm also a commercial helicopter
pilot and
that's what i do in my spare time i got
involved in uh
politics at the uh suggestions of some
of my clients after
going up to the state house and
testifying in public uh
hearings and on various subject matters
specifically private property rights
second amendment eminent domain and uh
preserving and maintaining our
individual liberties
and rights and that's why i'm here to
make sure that those
god-given natural unalienable rights are
maintaining preserves here in
the state of new hampshire
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative wallace
representative bolden
hi i'm amanda bolden uh this is my
fourth term
um from manchester i've known most you a
long time
um even representative marston and
i'm married my husband's also a state
rep
andrew bolden um i run a non-profit that
provides
thanksgiving meals um it's not paid
uh it's all volunteer and that means
that we use your donations
really wisely um i have a 14 year old
daughter
her name's sophia she's a full-time
student at velax which is a virtual
learning
academy it's new hampshire all
online school she's been in there since
before covet
so our lives didn't change a lot when
everything else changed
last year sophia was named the new
hampshire
finalist for the doodle for google
competition which is a national art
competition
so that was pretty cool because that she
was basically in the top 54
artists child artists in the country
art's really big deal to her and
i'm looking forward to being part of a
committee that i've always
regarded as nonpartisan thoughtful
cooperative and reasonable
and i want to thank the chairman for
advocating
for adding me to the committee
you know i just gave you the confidence
to lobby for yourself and you did a good
job because
here you are because and you had so many
bills that always became before the
committee i always ask why don't you
just
why aren't you on the committee was my
my confusion i said she should just sit
on the committee
but and i'm glad to have you on the
committee because you and i have had a
lot of conversations and
you know they've always been thoughtful
respectful even we often disagree so i'm
happy to have you aboard
i think the committee as a whole will
agree with me on that
representative true
thank you mr chairman i am
representative chris true i'm in my
fourth term
i represent the towns of auburn chester
and sandown i was born and raised in
southern maine
i got the wanderlust and moved all the
way down to southern new hampshire
i'm a graduate of university of maine
portland gorge
once we nicknamed that pogo you they
changed it to the university of southern
maine
my work history after college i went to
work for my uncle sam for a few years
and then i worked the rest of my life in
various management positions for various
transportation companies i'm looking
forward to a
a very good and interesting year
two years with criminal justice thank
you
thank you representative representative
knight
hi everyone this is my second term
i know almost all of you i
actually met john burt one day at the
dog park
we had no idea that we were both state
reps
we were just regular schmoes with our
puppies
and that was really cool um also
i have been this my
my first term i went before the criminal
justice committee several times
and i was um
just taken aback with the bipartisanship
of the community i was really fortunate
because
i'm very active with um really
um the most vulnerable people that have
been affected by the criminal justice
system and
in my district um like sex workers
or victims of trafficking and domestic
abuse
and how the criminal justice system has
affected them instead of rehabilitate
them
and um i'm really so i i work really
closely with a lot of victims
and um i re i'm here because i think
that we can come together
and make sure that people can be
productive members of society and and
not punish them necessarily for
things that were out of their control
and i i always appreciated the time and
respect
that both sides um gave
on on listening and even working in
especially
david welch um was really helpful
when it came to um protections against
certain certain people in the criminal
justice system and
i just i'm very grateful i just want to
say that
um i'm an artist i
[Music]
i'm a sculptor artist i actually
um went to the art school in manchester
when i first graduated high school in
and then i um they weren't i was very
curious
to learn more about glass and other
sculpture mediums so i
went in to california and
lived in oakland california for five
years
and now i came back here because i
am a new englander through and through
um i think we're made of some tougher
stuff
than some of our counterparts on the
west coast
and i'm here to bring it and also work
with you lovely people so
thank you and if you want to talk about
art
or anything like that i'm all ears all
the time
thank you representative knight
representative kraft
can you hear me now great
all right i'm a 42 year firefighter from
raymond
uh 29 last 29 years there was the fire
chief in raymond
um past president hampshire chief best
brother in the iu mutual
aid group uh wardens association uh
emergency management director for 29
years in raymond
uh i was 10 years in public service
and five years with a huge fire degree
we have a nuclear power plant
my wife's very uh very patient i've been
involved in a lot of meetings at night
and
he's a very patient person we're
presently subdividing my land
so that my daughter and grandchildren i
have three grandchildren
and my daughter crystal and her husband
can live
next door to me that's quite a process
uh dealing with the talent in that
my granddaughter is a fourth generation
firefighter and her husband will
come here find him full time
and this is my second term it was a
municipal income government last time
and i think with my background in the
fire service i wanted to get on this
committee and see what i can do to help
them
thank you
thank you representative pratt
representative bradley
hi um so this is my first term um
i represent manchester wars four five
six and seven
um i have lived in new hampshire all my
life
i am married and i have two daughters um
10 and 13.
um they both go to public school but
um obviously they're here with me now um
because of covid so that's been that's
been a bit um
interesting um i spent my career
doing advocacy so um i have my master's
in public policy
i've worked on health care women's
issues i focused a lot on
gun violence prevention so um
basically my whole career has been
revolved around that
i coach basketball i coach girls on the
run
i sit on the pto um at mclaughlin middle
school
so i'm just really i love my community i
love being a part of it and i just
i really look forward to working with
you all
thank you representative bradley and
i believe the last one representative
rhodes
hello everybody i'm jennifer rhodes
my husband and i of 25 years
i'm only 47 so my high school sweetheart
and i moved to new hampshire from just
outside of pittsburgh pennsylvania
five years ago and yes i
am a steeler fan because when you live
there you don't have a choice
pittsburgh is a drinking town with a
football problem
so that's that's that so i
actually sold real estate for 17 years
and when my daughter was going to
college
my husband and i decided to move to new
england
so we have lived here for five years now
this is my first term in the state house
i actually worked at
the school district in our town and
in june my position was eliminated due
to budgetary reasons so
i ran for the state house and got
elected
the um
[Music]
as far as the criminal justice committee
i i advocated for myself
really hard and really long to be
appointed to this
this committee and i'm actually very
very grateful that i
i had the opportunity to serve on this
committee and i thank the chairman
for asking me to step up to to be your
clerk so
i promise you the best i can for
everybody and just ask you to be
to be patient with me as i as i learned
the process of it
i do have some experience with you know
doing minutes and so forth for other
committees
but this will be the first time with
something on this level so i'm just
really happy to be here and thank
everybody
thank you representative rhodes and uh
mr chairman
could i could i add something i noticed
a lot of the
members have been commenting on their
children and grandchildren and i
neglected to do that
basically i have five children and
a number of step children so ends up
being 14
26 grandchildren and
23 plus great-grandchildren i haven't
figured it all out yet i just wanted to
add that in
that's more of a family forest not a
family tree
[Laughter]
congratulations to dad that's something
to be very proud of and
i'm hoping not to have that many kids
just
but don't tell my wife i said that
so i want to just i understand we have a
lot of questions
and there's a lot of uncertainty on how
we're going to do this
and how we're going to conduct the
committee i went through the list of all
the
bills that are lsrs and and bills that
are out there right now
this is unofficial but by my estimation
we're going to have about 50 to 60 bills
come before our committee
that's not take into consideration the
senate bills that will eventually come
our way
uh so we're going to have our work cut
out for us we're going to be on a very
tight schedule
now as you heard during the opening
remarks
there will be members of the public that
are participating
uh remotely and it for what i understand
it's likely to remain that way at least
for the rest of this year
now there as you can tell there'll be
plenty of technical issues that come up
so i'm not sure the official title
for this position but there will be two
people on the committee
that will help kind of be the liaison
of dealing with the technical issues
while we're in the committee meetings
it's important that the public has
access
to these hearings if they don't if
we would have to stop the hearing also
you know members of the committee we may
have our own technical issues so
i know uh and i spoke with each of these
representatives
beforehand representative david muse and
representative john burt
um they're not necessarily gonna be
working together on this issue but
either one of both of them will be kind
of
assisting the committee with any
technology issues we're having
communicating with the staff
beforehand my understanding there will
be some
[Music]
mild informal training i'm not again i'm
not sure what that's going to entail
just to make sure that you're familiar
with the software the staff
will still set up the hearings but it's
just critical that
if there is a technical difficulty
myself
the vice chair and the clerk we might be
oblivious to it
so i would ask that you know obviously
we all be conscious of especially
representative burt and representative
museum
i want to thank both of you both of you
representatives for
accepting that responsibility so
now we have uh deadlines coming up
for uh any bill that has a second
committee in february so we're gonna
have to
really push through a lot of bills and i
understand that
this is not ideal for any of us but due
to the volume of bills and restraints
that we have any bills that require a
subcommittee uh
you know when i say require that is
really deserving of a subcommittee
will likely be end up having to be
retained and when i say that
i understand that's frustrating and it's
really not my personal preference
or i don't believe that's any of our
preferences but
i would hate to see a bill fail
simply because it didn't get the
appropriate work that it needed
also keep in mind that passing a bill in
the house is great
we got to go through the senate so there
may be some uh
better strategy approach to having some
of these bills
worked on over the summer time having
the executive session in the
fall and then voting on in the beginning
of
2022. if we can avoid that that's great
but
it's just something i foresee being a
situation where
it won't be like last term or where we
had a if we had a bill
through a subcommittee all we would do
is
that uh the chairman would just create a
subcommittee and then within a week or
two would be done
we just may not have the luxury of doing
all these subcommittee meetings given
the limited zoom accounts we have
the limited uh options we have when we
can hold the hearings
so it is a work in progress and it's
just not going to be perfect that's a
reality
uh so because because of some of the
time constraints and this is not my
preference but it's just the reality and
i think it's important that
we all need to adapt to any situation
that comes before us whether it's the
cover 19 pandemic
or any other issues to come in the
future that
we may be holding some executive
sessions the same day as the public
hearings
and again that's not a preference but
it's really a matter of
we have to we want to make sure we meet
all our deadlines
because while we while we are meeting
today there's a limited amount of zoom
accounts available
for the committees i believe there's
only five so theoretically only five
committees can be holding a public
hearing at the same time
and i think we really got to be as
efficient as we can
with with our time and we got to
obviously use that time wisely also
uh for the the committee members who
choose to appear in person for the time
being
if we're at the lob my understanding is
going to open the
room up so we can spread out and
socially distance
uh but that would take up the room for
ways and means as well so while we are
meeting or holding a hearing our friends
in the ways and means committee
cannot meet uh for that matter so
they would have to find a different room
so unfortunately again
while we're meeting we want to again get
as much work as we
can guess much work done possible and i
think that that's
something we're going to have to do i
mentioned that they would open up the
the rooms so we can space out more
my understanding is is that they're
going to be
air filters or air scrubbers that
should recycle the air in the room
[Music]
up to five times per hour i'm not a uh
i'm not qualified to explain the science
behind that
i do know that i understand there'll be
some black light filteration
uh as well as um i believe hepa filters
but don't quote me on that
i more information that will come out
but that's something that will
obviously try to keep the room the air
clean and keep us safe
so one practice we may have to adopt
also not my preference but it may make
sense we may
hold multiple public hearings at the
same time
if the subject matter is very similar i
know that this
practice is often followed in the senate
uh going through the list of house bills
and lsrs
one i foresee we can do that with there
is a house bill on
recreational in regulation of cannabis
and then there's a
one involving home growing of cannabis i
would think that
those two bills could be heard in a
single hearing
we would still have a separate vote for
the executive session but
i recall both of those uh the bills of
last
term being very time consuming uh
some of the testimony will overlap some
of the public policy will overlap so
i believe we would that may be something
that's an example when we would do that
so keep that in mind uh
just a couple of uh other preferences
if anyone has any questions you know
feel free to call me anytime i don't
care if it's a saturday sunday
if it's eight o'clock at night nine
o'clock at night uh
during the day if i'm busy and i can't
answer i won't answer
but don't feel it it's it's it's a
bother
if you can't reach me please
uh reach out to the vice chair
representative welch
as you know he's been a member of the
body for over 30 years he
obviously i have no problem with you
going and
bring any questions to him to make sure
that you know
whatever it is just do what we got to do
when i do see each of
each member and for the returning
members i'm gonna
give you another one i handed out pins
last year that i
i thought was really the mark of our
committee but also a symbol of
unity on our committee that doesn't
matter what party you are
you all have the same pin and it's
it's it's for members of the criminal
justice public safety committee only
i suppose if you hand it out to someone
else i i wouldn't take offense but i
that's what that's for so if you see me
please ask for it
there will be some uh there will be a
the 2020 uh shooting the 2021 edition of
the
rsas that are relevant to our committee
we are going to receive those
those books i know they're going to be
sent to the our
the the our committee office i'm not
entirely certain how many if we're going
to mail those to people's residence or
what we're going to do from there
if you wish to pick it up i just ask
that you contact karen let her know that
you'll pick it up
uh yourself and then
representative welch is going to talk
about some of the facilities that we're
going to hopefully
at some point be able to go on a tour of
i don't see that happening in the
foreseeable future but
it's something that's very important
because i know we get a lot of headlines
when it comes to
cannabis and and firearm bills and
that gets a lot of headline but we have
a lot of other responsibilities i mean
fireworks
issues involving firefighters we're
going to have a lot of bills involving
law enforcement
and police reform but also the uh
correctional facilities the parole board
we have a lot of other responsibilities
that don't quite get the same press
but are still just as important to our
state and to our committee so
representative welch we'll do uh we'll
explain what some of those facilities
are
[Music]
all right there's four main
agencies that that we need to uh visit
when we
when we can top on the list is a state
prison
we deal with a lot of stuff that put
people in prison
and sometimes we deal on things on bills
to help people get back
out state prison is
high on my list for for visitation
but given the current circumstances
it's unlikely we'll be able to do that
this year
police centers and training police
standards and training
that's why we train all the law
enforcement people and we also train the
corrections
officers so that is another area
again when we can we should visit that
the the fire academy the fire academy
now let's see the fire academy
uh is where we train the firefighters uh
we don't have many bills dealing with uh
firefighters but
occasionally we do but we also use that
as a
we have the fireworks review committee
that meets over there
several other groups that do meet at the
fire academy
and say well we we paid for it with tax
dollars so it's something we should
visit
the forensic lab dealing with
drugs uh we there's been some expansion
of the forensic lab we have a new
new person over there whose name i can't
remember right at the moment
but we should go to the forensic lab
those are the four top areas that we
need to visit
there are a few others uh
motor vehicle not so much
uh let's see
those are the four main ones that we
will visit at some point when we get the
opportunity
and and if we can go to those things
it's important that we go as a committee
so
everyone gets to see what everyone else
sees
that's basically it turn it back to the
chairman
i don't know whose dog that is because i
think all i think half of you have a dog
but
anyway thank you representative welsh
there's another topic i wanted to just
uh
there we go all right dive into
quickly while we're doing the remote
meetings as we are now if you
want to raise your hand and i can see
the video
obviously put your hand up and we'll
kind of go that route
and i'll call on you
all right if if your hands up and i
don't
recognize it you know just keep waving
the more you wave the more
the more we'll see it and then obviously
it's helpful for myself and the clerk to
do that
uh i'm going to try to make it a point
to
go around for the people who aren't on
video if they're calling in
you know i don't if they have i would
prefer the obviously people to be on
video just like we see
see the person but at the same time i
wouldn't be able to tell if you're
waving so try to alert myself or the
the vice chair or the clerk that you're
you have a question
in respect to some other issues i wanted
to cover
so regardless of of
what party you're affiliated with
the people who are on this community and
even some of the members of the house
that are returning but are on the
committee for the first time
they know that we work together as a
team we eat lunch together
we all sit together uh we had i think we
had a pretty good bond last year
we worked through some we had some
difficult things that came up
and i think we worked we worked through
it together as a committee and i think
it
even though there was hurt feelings at
times i think often
we came out closer and better as a
result of that and
from my perspective i want to one make
it clear whatev
everyone has a clean slate we're
starting over with that so
i think we can work together and
accomplish some really good things
i i will say and it's my preference and
this is not a rule
it's not a it's not a household it's not
a committee rule
that if there's ever any issue with
myself or any member of the committee
for that matter
that you have a concern with whether
it's their behavior
whether it's the rhetoric they use or
something they said
um all i all i would recommend
is that i felt feel that
if i had an issue with any member of
this committee that i could direct it to
that person directly
i i don't need to put it on social media
i would buy
and i'll just use um myself as an
example if you had an
issue with what i was doing i would say
feel free to address with me directly
representative gather i know i'm going
to use this example because
there was a incident last term where
representative gathright was not
particularly happy with my behavior uh
and we had a she has to speak with me
privately
she had a very a lot of powerful words
to say
and we but at the same time it was a
productive
constructive conversation that two
professionals had
and although although i didn't agree
with everything she said
it didn't mean a lot to me that she was
one comfortable enough
to approach me and talk to me about an
issue she had
with me and we were able to work it out
and hear each other out it was never any
voices raised
despite how assertive she was and
confident she was she was right to the
point and i remember
i always said although i didn't agree
with everything she said her criticism
was fair
and and i appreciated that she brought
that to me it wasn't something that was
on twitter
or facebook or any of that and i would
just say that
you know when we if there is an issue
and i see it on twitter or facebook
first
i mean to me that it meant a lot to me
that she did that and
i think that i would just hope that you
all have that
that uh feeling because we're going to
work together on a lot of different
things
i see if you burn a bridge on one topic
it might that bridge may stay burned for
other topics and i think that that
pushes us further apart
so if and i'm telling you
and i expect everyone to if someone does
raise a concern you don't have to agree
with the concern
but give that member the respect of
explaining
exactly what you know what their concern
is
and and i think that will make us
actually bring us closer together not
push us further apart so
we have a new person joining but
we have representative conley has joined
the meeting
so does anyone have any questions about
what i just
that the issue i talked about with
addressing the committee with any
any concerns they may have
okay thank you and what i what i will
say is that
i looked at a lot of the bills that are
coming for our committee a lot of them
are bipartisan bills sponsored by
several members of this committee and
that's a very that was good to see
so that's that's something that we're
going to have as well uh
representative connolly we did briefly
go around and let everyone introduce
themselves to the committee
explain their professional background
and
any other background about their
themselves that they want to share with
the committee
if you'd like to share any information
about yourself the floor is not yours
it's like his audio isn't working his
audio wasn't working um
he may not need to just um walk out with
the media and log back in
this is why we have two two people in
charge of technology
mr chairman i have a question
representative burt
in the past
if a member on the committee was
a sponsor or co-sponsor of a bill
if they did not testify they were
allowed to sit
in the chair and still ask questions but
if they testified
they could still sit in the chair but
they weren't you know their chair they
just weren't allowed to ask questions
how are you going to proceed with that
thank you representative for the
question what i will say is that if you
are the prime sponsor or co-sponsor of
any
bill uh it's not gonna it's like in the
committee room where you can get up and
leave your seat
i would say that you are not it's not
appropriate for you to ask
any questions during the public hearing
of any of the witnesses now
the other scenario that can happen and
is that even if you're not a sponsor or
co-sponsor
you're still free to testify before the
committee as a member of the public
it's not common but it can happen i
actually did it last year
uh at the request of a representative a
representative who
wanted me to present to the committee
thought i would do a better job
so i did that for him even though i
didn't support the bill
but i did it anyway as a because i gave
him my word that i would i
will consider myself removed from the
committee for the purposes of that
public hearing
so either way you would not be permitted
to ask any questions
uh if it's a bill that
when it comes to the executive session
you are still allowed to participate
as you know regardless of uh
because the public hearing's closed so
you can then vote on the bill as a
sponsor or co-sponsor
um mr chairman can you clarify when you
say you consider yourself removed from
the committee for the hearing do you
mean
um you can't sit in your chair let's you
know imagine
there's no covet and we're in the lobby
are you saying you wouldn't be able to
sit in your chair
as a committee member
it it's the preference that you not sit
in the chair
just it's again it's the perception of
you sitting there even though you didn't
ask any questions you still look like it
still gives the perception that you're
participating in the hearing
we all may understand that you're not
but from the public's perspective
uh i it is my preference that you sit in
the
audience while you do that i know when i
did that when i
testified last year on a real before
committee that same one i was referring
to
the room we had the double room and the
room was full there was actually nowhere
to stand or sit so i
kind of snuck back to my chair but i
pushed my chair as far back as i can
just to not give the perception i was
sitting at the table
but while we're doing these remotely
it's not really
uh a way for you i'm not asking you to
turn yours your camera off right and
that's
i don't think it's going to matter in
that sense but just refrain from asking
any questions of the witnesses
and so that's that's how it would work
and that's solution not
not a it hasn't been really
too much of a problem in this committee
but something to be aware of
another time another time constraint
issue i
and uh this may not be the case every
time
but we may limit the time of testimony
for all the bills again just just to
make sure we can get through everything
um i anticipate that being three minutes
uh depending on the the uh
length of the bill we may allow an
exception uh
for the prime sponsor or the person
who's presenting the bill to the
committee
to perhaps have maybe up to five minutes
representative bourdain
uh yes uh i'm more concerned about right
now about
the calendar of whom we're going to be
working you say we have 50
60 bills are we going to have a
particular day
or half a day which we are be
hearing bills and
is it are we going to do them as a clump
rather than
individual times for testimony
thank you representative bourdain it it
is it's depend on the bill i
i mentioned earlier that the
recreational cannabis and the home
growing
of cannabis those may be done kind of as
a one hearing kind of lump close
together
i just anticipate that being a very long
hearing
so we put those together some of the
bills uh
you know if we want to talk about issues
involving law enforcement although it
covers the same subject matter
they're very very different issues so i
don't really see a lot of those being
grouped together and that's also very uh
it's more of a
very specific issues raised by each bill
so i don't think it would be
uh it might be much more difficult to do
that
with those type of bills so when we say
clump them together though
i would anticipate and ask everyone to
plan
that if we have a public hearing on a
bill at least anticipate that we may
have the executive session
that same day and again that's
unfortunately
due to the time constraints and so when
when a bill is noticed in the calendar
um i'm going to ask to be noticed that
it
for an executive session as well just so
we can
try to get through everything and
obviously if if it's the bill's not
ready
to uh to go forward on that you know
again we have the time constraint so i
i'm afraid that if we don't
keep it moving we may lose it so the
other option is we always can
retain the bills and work on over the
summertime
so when i say clump i was talking about
not assigning particular
uh starting times for a set of bills
because as we saw in some
hearings last year they the bills took
sometimes five to ten minutes instead of
a half hour that was allocated to her
and also are we going to have a day of
the week in which we
are going to be hearing bills because i
need to sort of know what my calendar
looks like
in regards to scheduling it's my
understanding that at some
very shortly i will know there'll be
specific days
that we will be allowed to meet you know
hypothetically
mondays and wednesdays may be days that
we're allowed to
meet so i don't have the specific days
but it should be relatively consistent
uh
where once we know those days i'll be
sure the whole committee is made aware
of it
when it comes clubbing them together
i'm going to try to notice them very
close in time to each other
and myself and representative wells are
going to sit down and try to
kind of try to master the schedule here
to see
anticipate how long we anticipate the
hearings will take
we don't want to uh be in a situation
where
we're sitting around for a half hour
because of the way we notice the time
uh i will notice maybe the other option
is you may notice
four or five bills at nine o'clock in
the morning four or five deals at ten
o'clock in the morning
just to kind of spread it out so people
have an idea when their bill will be
recalled
but again it's in order for us to keep
this moving we don't want to
have to sit around even 15-20 minutes
lost we can get through a public hearing
in that time i think it's
uh it would be unfortunate for us not to
make good use of that time
presented abbas uh i have a question
we voted on a rule uh over at the
drive-in activity at unh
regarding lobbyists and whether they
would testify before
or after and i think they left it up to
the chairman
to decide you know which way they're
going to do it
what is your preference to
letting lobbyists testify before the
citizens
so my my respect to that
rule and i think when we passed it
two years ago the only reason why i
didn't support it is that i thought
that the chairman of the committee
should have the discretion to conduct
the hearing as they saw appropriate as
because every hearing is going to be
different
it is my personal preference that
members of the public
testify before lobbyists however
if there is a lobbyist here that's on a
time constraint
you know as a professional courtesy
sometimes you may show
i think it's an option to show them a
preference but
in this term particularly we're all on a
time constraint so
we're all going to be trying to work
together quite often
members of the public also other
representatives have
multiple bills going before multiple
committees and may have
multiple hearings they have to go
through go testify
in front of so if someone comes to me
saying i have a 10 o'clock
in fro in the finance committee and
i have a 9 30 in criminal justice
if whether that's a private individual
or a lobbyist or a representative
whoever
i would try to accommodate that just to
make sure that they're able to to
testify
especially if it's brought to my
attention in advance but generally
speaking
it's my preference that members of the
public testify first but
again we're dealing because while we're
dealing in these difficult times
i don't want anyone to miss anything so
representative welch
yes in ordinary circumstances this is
before colburn
uh the sponsors would speak first
give you the impression of the bill and
a lobbyist sometimes can give you a lot
of good information
but generally speaking they are paid and
they'll sit there
and they'll wait until everybody else is
through and then they'll come up and
pass in a pink card
i think you're going to have to learn
which lobbyists do that
and kind of let them know
where they stand in in the pecking order
also for people testifying if we're
testifying
again pre-colburn and you have people
that come from the
say up around errol or berlin
they have a lot of distance to travel
and when you get to the public you
should take those that travel the
farthest
first it's just just a thought
thank you representative wells and and
that's one of the reasons why i think
having that it'd be somewhat
discretionary is important because this
different circumstances for every
witness and you would hate to see
someone
swapped in line or because because of
ray handcuffed by a rule but at the same
time
i agree with what representative walsh
is saying if someone has a two-hour
drive or commute i think that's relevant
and
for anyone in the audience to just
listen to us talk you know
please submit your cards right away and
if in
it's submit your card and if you want to
wave off that's fine
but we also want to try to gauge how
much how long the hearing
may take so we think if there's only
three
cards handed in and we think it's gonna
be done relatively soon then we get two
three more cards
the master schedule that representative
welch and i are gonna try to put
together will be
disrupted by that so it would be better
for us to know if everyone handed the
cards in
earlier there's no rule saying you have
to do that but that would be
preferred representative marston
thank you mr chairman for recognizing me
i appreciate that
uh i don't want to go trip back to uh
john burt's question
and put in some words and get some feel
for what we're talking about
if you have a bill and you present it to
the committee
you're then going to turn around and
restrict my rights for
free speech that i don't get to ask
questions
if somebody testifies and they testify
negatively about my bill i don't get the
question
their motives or i don't get the
question why they're doing what they're
doing
i am then stymied i don't understand
that
and is that a rule or is that a courtesy
thank thank you for the thank you for
the question so
that was first of all that was the
practice of the committee my
understanding is
that that is a rule that has been
followed by
the committees uh it was followed last
year
and i i think again it's i don't believe
it's a restriction on your speech
because i
assure every member of this committee
you will have your opportunity to speak
and if you're if you are the prime
sponsor and you present the bill
and a witness says something that you
would like to respond to
i i'm not going to make any promises
because i already explained that i'm
going to limit testimony
but for example if you're the prime
sponsor for bill and
about your um allotted five minutes of
testimony
you can reserve your time and i could
call you again
so maybe if you opened with three
minutes i would reserve
again if you're allowed up to five
minutes i would love i would maybe
consider
that as an option to respond to certain
uh points people made but also remember
that
during the executive session if anyone
says anything that's
you believe to be inaccurate or
misleading or you just disagree with
during the executive session you have
the opportunity to say
and address those that testimony as well
so that's something to point out and
also if you are going to be testifying
on a bill or and you're the prime
sponsor
the other members of the committee or
your committee know that you may
not be able to ask the question so keep
in mind which trust each other to have
each other's
uh backs on that that knowing that
someone may not be able to ask a
question but if they
have a particular question i think we
should offer everyone that courtesy
representative welch yeah to respond to
representative marston if you're a
member of the committee and you're a
prime sponsor or even a co-sponsor of a
bill
and you feel the need to to correct
something that's been said
that's what the executive session is for
executive session is kind of free
wheeling
you you will not be restricted in an
executive session
and the other thing is the rule is we do
not debate
a witness we only ask questions to draw
out the information that we need to make
a decision on the bill
and sometimes sometimes we lose track of
that
so that's up to the chairman to
recognize
you don't debate a witness you'll you
will have your day in
in court at the executive session
representative gathering
just wanted to let you know that um
representative conley is still having
problems with um
speaking into you know with his audio
so i did say to him that if he wanted us
to know something if he put it in chat
i would read it to you okay
and and representative connolly i assure
you whether it's
today or at our next meeting once we get
your microphone working we'll allow you
to
introduce yourself to the committee it
properly but uh
thanks for hearing us out and just
remember he can't talk back so let's
give him
let's be nice uh representative burt
thank you mr chairman uh my first four
terms
uh in the house two of the first terms
that i was you know on criminal justice
i believe under uh chairman welch and
also under
chairman thall we allowed the
co-sponsors
as long as they did not speak on the
bill
we allowed them to participate in the
committee and ask
questions now if they were if they were
the prime sponsor
yes i understand that you get
one you know you have to speak on the
bill so you don't get to sit and ask all
the questions
but if you want to not speak
in front of the committee as a
co-sponsor
then you have the right in the first
four terms that i was there
under chairman cushing he was the one
that changed that
in my fifth term and said no you know if
you're a co-sponsor or any sponsor or
anything like that you can't speak
but my first four terms we were allowed
to speak and
again it was under chairman tall and
chairman welch
representative bur what i will do is i
will consult with
with the clerk on this my understanding
the rule is that if you're the sponsor
of a bill
then you should not be questioning
the way any of the witnesses now uh what
i
also recommend to people is that is the
rule and i am correct with that rule
then maybe be selective on how you
sponsor bills coming for the committee i
know when i would ask the co-sponsor of
a lot of bills that came before the
committee
part of my concern was if i co-sponsor
all these bills to come before the
committee how could i serve as the
chairman of the committee because i
won't be be able to participate in
any of the hearings now with that being
said
what i will do is i i will at least
discuss your concern with the clerk to
get some clarification on that but
i think it's important just the
perception of the public again to make
sure that
it does not look like there's any
conflicts amongst any of the
representatives sitting on the committee
so
i i will look into that further without
my unders that was my understanding of
the rule
and i i respect what you're saying so
i'll be sure to look into that
sorry and mr chairman one final thing
is is make sure when you speak to the
clerk if you don't mind a
distinct between the difference sponsor
which i understand and co-sponsor
because
i have co-sponsored a few bills that i
thought we were going to go back to the
old rules so my name's on it
but in the committee if it does come to
our committee i do want to
participate and in the past it always
was allowed until
chairman cushing changed that
thank you representative i'll be sure to
distinguish the two because i understand
the
difference representative muse
yes i had some questions just about the
in-person meetings
and some of the requirements for folks
who are going to be attending so one of
the things i'm curious about
is whether or not legislators who are
going to be attending
uh committee meetings in person are
going to be required to wear masks
the other question that i have is for
legislators
uh who are attending in person what
steps are being taken to make sure
that uh they are miked properly so that
members of the public who are attending
remotely
as well as any legislators who might be
attending remotely
uh can actually hear what's going on in
the meeting
so in regards to the whether people are
miked properly that's
part of the role of having more than one
tech person to make sure that
you can be heard i think it would make
sense to do a mic check or a sound check
before we start just to make sure
we can all be heard i don't know exactly
where different microphones will be set
up in the room
so i i can't answer that definitively
right now
so i do know that i can imagine there'll
be more than one
just because we're going to be spread
out ourselves in the room
at least six feet apart so i think
having one microphone wouldn't really
work so i i can imagine it'll be a few
of them
will where they'll be set up i'm not
sure if they'll be individual
microphones or whatnot i know last term
we started
recording audio recording our committee
hearings
uh do you i don't recall how many
microphones in the room but i know there
was more than one
at that time i think there was for those
there was maybe one
i know there was one between myself and
the person sitting next to me so i
couldn't answer that
definitely uh in regards to mass
mandates or whatever
you know how we're going to conduct the
hearings and all these rules
it's going to depend on really how many
people are present
and that are going to participate in
person uh also i need to know more about
what the
makeup of the room's going to be uh i
need to know
exactly how it's being cleaned and then
the air is being cleaned
and i i what i do know is that i want it
to be consistent
it's not going to be a committee
specific rule that on this committee
we're doing that
we're going to have to do this or on
this committee we're wearing mass but
other committees don't it's going to be
my understanding it needs to be a
uniform if it's going to be a rule like
that's going to come
a uniform rule for all the committees
what i will say to the people sitting on
the committee
i'm not interested in having any
scientific arguments about masks i think
we've all had them more than once
already
and we don't need to go down that road
i'm not aware of any of us
having being a doctor on that subject so
we don't need to do that
i would just ask that uh regardless what
you
where position your you feel on that
topic that we try to be as respectful to
everyone on the committee
as possible um and i think that's
important to really
focus on that i i wouldn't want anyone
to feel
disrespected whether it you know
regardless of what we're talking about
so try to welcome everyone you can every
which way possible
representative pantholakis yes wouldn't
it gov
governor's mandate require that we do
that
in the committee room
thank thank you for your question so
that's a legal question
uh my opinion which um
this is my opinion i'm just one person
my understanding
is that an executive order or a state of
emergency
does not necessarily apply to
the legislative branch because of
separation of power issues just like
uh i recall many years ago when i lived
in
south boston there was an emergency
because of the marathon
bombing and although there was a
complete shutdown during that tragic
incident
the court system was not subject to that
order because it's a separate division
of government
and i had a court hearing that day and i
was trying to figure out how do i get to
the courthouse
without violating the executive order
and naturally no one would take my call
at the courthouse
so i had my work cut out for me the time
i got there they sent me home
saying we're not doing any hearings
would be nice to answer the phone but
so my understanding is we wouldn't have
to necessarily uh
we would necessarily fall into that but
also the executive order
is only my interpretation is only
operative
if you're if you're able to solicit
distance i don't believe that there is a
mass mandate
so to the extent that it does apply i
think we would be exempt
if we're socially distancing now six
feet apart
that's that's great it doesn't mean you
should or should not wear a mask based
on the fact that you're socially
distancing but i don't wouldn't say
we're violating the executive order
thank you representative newman
yes mr chairman my question is for
public hearings work sessions
and executive sessions do you anticipate
that there will come a time where there
will be no virtual capability for the
legislators
to participate and vote in those
meetings
well to answer your question is
all right i'm going to operate with
what's in front of me now right now
we're doing we're going to be doing it
remotely
because i know that the community rooms
aren't even set up yet
so i i don't if i anticipate something
i don't want to create a perception that
this is how we're going to do it when
we're not
i think it's as we've seen with this
pandemic
it's a forever changing situation yeah
if i tell you something today two days
from now it can be outdated so i don't
want to
tell you we're going to do something
that we're in and we're not going to do
it i think what we need to do is get to
get the room set up and see how it's
going to look
then i know for the time being the
public hearings
we're going to be able to do them on
zoom or remotely and it's at the choice
of the
representative uh whether they want to
appear in person or not
now that could change but again i think
it's a it's a work in progress
follow-up question a follow-up question
would just be
the you said there is a potential for us
to have
um public hearings and executive
sessions
on the same day and so that
in my opinion it seems like that could
bring the date
when we may be where we may not have a
virtual capability
a lot closer than the far future so it's
something to really think about thank
you for your answer
thank you representative newman and and
again with the executive sessions being
on the same day as the public hearing
i don't think that that was ever it's
none of our
preference that's not my first choice
and i don't i don't
believe it really it's it's policy that
we want to follow long term
but given the time distance and pandemic
that we're in
uh we're doing we have to really
handle this a lot of hearings not the
way we would like to i think i speak for
all of us we would love to meet in
person
and and sit together and get this done
in a non-covenanting world but it's just
it's unfortunate so i don't i don't want
to represent newman
yeah just to follow up i just wanted to
be clear about it
i don't have an objection to doing that
my my real concern is
the lack of a virtual capability for
legislators to participate
thank you
thank you and if there's any members of
the committee who have any
issues with their systems their
computers
please let myself know let the committee
assistant know
let representative welch know and let
the ranking member uh
you know let representative gather right
now just let everyone know that you're
having these issues because again
we would hate to see someone not
participate because of uh
technical difficulties representative
welch
and i just wanted to remind you that
being chairman of a committee
gives you a lot of discretion
in how the committee operates now i
think
war and i certainly are in the category
where
we probably want to wear a mess and
participation in person is very
important to me
i don't like zoom meetings i mean i
understand the necessity of it
but i don't think we can really do a
good job for the people of the state
with a zoom meeting i really think we
need to be there
hopefully we can figure out how to do
that and
i'm i a little reluctant to speak for
laura but i'm going to wear a mask
i'm 80 years old i'll be 81 in february
i don't want to curtail something that
i want to go to 100. but
you as a chairman you have a lot of
discretion on how things
operate and going to the clerk all the
time
is not going to it's not going to be
very helpful because sometimes the clerk
doesn't
really understand what goes on in
committee
he's clerk has never been a chairman
that's it my my me deferring to the
clerk was
an effort to not debate too long with
the representative from goffstown
because him and i can
debate topics for hours whether we're on
the same side or against each other
which we
we always seem to be arguing time so
the interest of everyone out in time
constraints i'm going to look into that
i know there's some
i do know it was with respect to
representative burt's question
there is some disagreement on that rule
uh but i
the way i i look at it is that if you're
the my interpretation give a
sponsor or prize sponsor then you
wouldn't be testifying and when it comes
to
uh meeting in person if it
if it comes down to you know
every you the members of the committee
if it comes down to wearing a mask and
not
you know you're free to voice your
concern with that you know
i'm looking at it as if it comes down to
getting 20 people to meet together in a
room
and it's going to come down to wearing a
mask i would hope that
i me the issue of wearing a mask or a
face shield is not what prevents that
from happening
but i haven't got that commitment from
everyone on the committee yet so
without that commitment i'm i mean not
inclined to make any type of
or suggest any type of mandate like that
if if i get 20 people or
19 whatever tell me if we wear masks
i'll come in and meet in person
i agree 100 percent meeting in person
nothing is
is going to replace that uh the people
on this committee
or you know representative newman from
nashville you know i consider you
a good friend you and i talk on the
phone about when we talk half the stuff
we talk about
it's unrelated to what we're doing as
representatives i mean i consider your
friend i consider a lot of you friends
and i think those relationships were
built when we met in person and i think
as can we get business done through zoom
of course we can but are we going to
develop those relationships
you know representative bradley you're a
new member
and it's it's great to meet you i i
feel that if we met in person it would
be much better
and we can kind of get a feel for each
other and that's when i say oh i'm
approachable needs to talk to
i feel that the people who serve me
serve with me on this committee
would stand by that and know that that's
the case and just as i'm comfortable
approaching you know representative muse
of representative gather right
even representative antolokis who can be
very i'm i still
can't vote for you because we we work
together and we develop those
relationships so
that's for me that's really really
important and some of the members
of the of of the committee who are
returning members but didn't serve
last year you know we didn't we didn't
have that
same you know working relationship but i
think developing that
is going to make us all better
representatives and make us a better
committee as a whole so i would hope
that we can do that and
if people tell me that the difference is
a map
it comes down to wearing masks that that
will
be taken into consideration but i
haven't heard enough people
commit to that so but maybe i'll
go through and if anyone wants to speak
on that and
please please uh do so representative
knight
um thank you chairman for recognizing me
to ask a question
since i am only a second termer
um i am still learning about rules
and i wanted to circle back to what
representative pintilakis
asked about confliction with
the governor's orders and in regards to
house rules
do house rules are they only protecting
house members
is would it be different for members of
the public
coming to speak would they still be
responsible for upholding a dif like a
different
law so just a point of clarification
there
thank you for the question i think
that's also a legal question so i'm just
speaking casually as one individual not
speaking so don't if any get in trouble
for
violating any any mass mandate because
of what i said that your
don't don't don't bring me down with you
no i mean if you're going to look into
this
if you were going to follow up with that
those questions i would really
appreciate it if you looked into that
one too so
one one to answer that question though
is
members of the public if we all meet in
person
at the at the lob members of the public
will still be
uh testifying testifying and
participating
uh through zoom so they won't be in the
in the room with us
it would only be the members of the
committee present
in the room is my understanding there
may be a staff member as well
assisting us with some of the technical
side of things
so that the issue of the mass mandate
and as it applies to members of the
public wouldn't
wouldn't really be come up because they
wouldn't be in the room
i will say that if we ever did have live
witnesses appear
uh in i would think it would be
disingenuous for us to expect them to
wear a mask and us not to
i think that that's not good practice
so if we ever got to that point i would
encourage that all of us
uh be united on that because we that's
to me
you know not don't do as i just don't do
as i say
not as i do i don't i don't follow that
so i would i would
change my my opinion on that very
quickly but i don't i don't see that
happening at least in the first
year unfortunately representative
welcome representative hopper
uh thank you mr chair uh uh having
served on a lot of committees
one of the uh um basic rules
has been to
not bring any uh like political attire
when you come into the committee the the
premise is you're trying to make
uh citizens that come to the state house
feel as comfortable as possible
so if i came in with my mega hat on
people that were on the other side of
the political spectrum might be offended
and
i think they're be under the impression
they're not going to get a fair hearing
now that we're on zoom it does it
follow that we should be cognizant of
what is in the room with us in other
words
if i have an irish republican army
flag in the back back i don't have one
but if i had something like that in the
back of me
or or uh political uh activist
type paraphernalia around me is that
going to be
uh prohibited so that we don't alienate
members of the public who will be seeing
us
thank you thank you my understanding of
that
the issue of you know having attire that
it represents a political uh
for example a maga hat uh at the
speaker when he would rule on that it
would have to do with the fact that he
was a candidate
um at this point in time uh
president trump's not not a candidate i
i would
prefer no one i don't believe wearing a
hat is
in line with the dress code from what i
understand
but assuming that it was and you were
allowed to wear a hat i would say that
he's not a candidate
with that being said uh
and i voiced this to the committee last
year because i know there was some
issues with
certain actually involved people
bringing maga hats to the committee
hearings i will say that
it's not much of a surprise if if
someone on this committee wore
a joe biden pin or whatever i wouldn't
personally i wouldn't have any issue
with that i can understand that members
of the public
i would hope are not intimidated by that
and they and they should not be
intimidated by that i
but i would not recommend wearing
anything that this
that distracts from what we're doing
here and i think
myself uh representative welch and
representative wallace learned that the
hard way
even though we you know we may wore
something to mean one thing
and it was interpreted to mean something
else and all
that spiral out of control relatively
relatively quickly
but so i would ask them to be conscious
of what you wear
for that reason hello representative
sue newman good to see you today
so that that's my thought on that uh
in regards to your background again
you don't want to have anything that's
distracting because again we're
testifying
uh people are testifying before us so
avoiding those distractions would be
something i would just encourage
now if someone has a something that's
um you know whether it's a republican
flag or a democratic flag
i'm not aware of a rule that makes that
prohibited i will say i mean if i'm i'm
a registered
republican i'm elected as a republican
official if i had any type of republican
symbol in the background i don't think
that would come as much a surprise to
anyone
just my opinion
representative muse
yeah thank you i just had a follow-up
question on the uh
on the uh on the the mass requirement
issue
i'm curious if in the setup of
uh the committee rooms and uh you you
mentioned that there are hepa filtering
and some other things that are taking
place
are you aware of any public health
expert who's actually
basically said that it would be okay for
people
uh who are attending meetings in those
room to be attending them
without masks or is it being assumed
that this level of protection would be
okay
for or the level of risk would be
acceptable
if people in the room were actually
masking up and
and one of the other things that i did
want to say too is that
with the pandemic i mean we've had
almost 800 deaths in new hampshire we've
had
close to 400 000 in the united states
there's a new covet variant
that's in connecticut right now and that
probably is going to hit here
there may be a couple of people on the
committee who may be
in line to get vaccinated you know at
some point
in you know in february or june but what
i what i would ask is a courtesy
um just to other members on the
committee given the fact that we're all
vulnerable
to this uh and that you know i think
most of us mentioned the family members
that we care about and our grandchildren
and our kids and everything else
just as a matter of courtesy uh i would
ask
everybody on the committee that you know
when and if we do get together in person
that um this is just something that we
all do
i mean i i would do it to protect any of
you and
and i would hope that you would do it to
protect each other to protect me to
protect my family
it's the one thing that we can do and i
know we have varying opinions on
how comfortable it is and and you know
and ultimately how effective it is
um but um uh dr chan
our state public health br ex public
health
experts uh along with dr falchi at the
national level i mean
they're basically all saying that this
is some the one thing that we can do as
individuals that would really help
and just to sort of start fresh
if we want to kind of build that
atmosphere
of trust and collaboration and working
together that i think we've been talking
about
that would really be a great way for
people to display
that you know we are on the same team at
least when it comes to dealing with this
pandemic
thank you representative news my so
first of all
no one's assuming anything we're not
just oh here's an air filter i saw on
amazon let's uh
put it in the lob and turn it on i don't
think it's that i
my understanding there were engineers
that were retained and there's
there is some scientific backing on
what's being done now i haven't asked
the question
will these air filters be sufficient
enough
to you know replace the need for a mask
um even if i'm told yes i you know if
i still would and say i'm gonna wear a
mask either way
that's just me all right so i'm not
whether the the scientist engineer
whatever the title is tells me
oh you don't need one these air filters
they got it taken care of
i'm still gonna wear one anyway so
that's just me
um i i for people who agree with me in
fall that league
great but i don't know if one
necessarily replaces the other
and i haven't asked that question but i
do know that the people that are
engineering the or re organizing the
lob to try to make it as safe as
possible
uh this is a this is their expertise so
i would my explanation may not be doing
their work justice but i do know that
there's a lot of work being done
there was a lot of consultation being
done and
unfortunately the progress was delayed
sadly with the passion of speaker hinch
so
that was kind of uh that delayed the
process so i know them the air filters
literally arrived yesterday from what i
understand
so they're not even i don't know what
the status those are and again we're
going to try to get us up and running as
fast as possible
representatives have a follow up
um no only only just to say that no
matter
i think we deal with the same issue in
restaurants and and i think one of the
things that we found is that
a lot of people in new hampshire when it
comes to eating indoors at restaurants
have been voting with their feet
um and that it has hurt our restaurants
but
one of the things that we hear
consistently is being in a closed
uh space with other people um during
this pandemic
is just simply not a good idea so what
i'm saying is
um while i think it's great that um
you know that uh that the house is
taking steps
to make these rooms safer uh for us to
meet in
there's one step that we can all take
ourselves that will just increase the
level of safety and decrease the level
of risk
um even more and and and frankly
my constituents here in portsmouth would
expect me
to be asking these questions um because
one of the things that i'm very much
aware of
is the potential for any of us to bring
this back to our communities and i don't
think that's and something any of us
really wants to do i know
you know mr chairman your committee has
your community has been especially hard
hit
uh during covet i think salem is around
the
the third or fourth uh highest um you
know
incidents of cases in the state and and
more deaths than anybody wants to think
about and i just think that
again part of our responsibility you
know as
as legislators is to do what we can to
sort of tamp this thing down
and and sometimes that behavior just
needs to translate to
the things that we do at the personal
level and the example that we set for
other people
so i think new hampshire new hampshire
is really going to be watching all of us
to see what we're doing
um and and i think it's really important
that we show leadership in this area
thank you representative newson and i
you did say a great point and
you know we'll just reiterate this to
the public that
you know i'm 37 years old i you know
god bless me if i were ever to contract
over 19 i would fall into the 99.9
range but that's it's not about just me
it's about the people that i'm around
you know i i have
i mentioned earlier my wife's pregnant
and that puts her in a high risk
category so
uh what may not affect you as much may
affect someone else
whether it's in your household or person
sitting next to you
and i think that just emphasizing that
that don't look at
just as how this affects you it's how it
affects everyone around you
so i think it's important to just always
remember that that
everyone has different circumstances i'm
not asking anyone to
disclose their um private medical
information to the committee
but if there's members of this committee
that i know
are considered to be a higher risk uh
and that's something that i think we
should be conscious of as well now
whether we do something that that
scientifically works or not is is
not the point if it's something that
just even if it's a 10
help whatever i mean i would i would
hope that we all just do our best to
make everyone
comfortable and welcome not just members
of the public but members of the
committee make them feel welcomed
to come and uh participate in the
committee meetings
him bolden
thanks um i actually had three questions
my first one
was have you picked a name yet for your
daughter
it's uh well ultimately it's up to my
wife
so it's not supposed to say that's okay
we haven't picked anything
it's up to her i will uh
i will let you guys know once we once
she arrives at a conclusion
my my second question was um
so i've been trying to follow along and
it sounds like
only the legislators and staff will be
allowed in the lob and if the public
wants to give testimony there to do that
over zoom is that correct
correct right and so i was wondering um
what was the uh maybe this isn't like
something that you can answer
but it seems like if if it's not
appropriate for the public to be in the
building why are there legislators in
the building
and it you know it just seems like
wouldn't it all be simpler if we just
did everything
via zoom but maybe that's not something
that you can speak to
it just doesn't make a lot of sense you
know it's well the difference is
if the members of the and i'm just
speaking i'm not i'm speaking on behalf
of just
myself here if the if there's 20 of us
in our in a room and we
separate the wall with it's normally
reserved for ways and means and we are
all able to socially distance
the 20 of us and we're able to filter
the air
i would assume that that air filtration
is somewhat taking a consideration that
you're not going to have 50 people in
the room
or 60 people in the room if you open
that committee meeting
to the general public in the double even
in the double room
it would be very difficult to socially
distance
with members of the public uh two the
and we'll need someone to enforce that
in socially distancing
and to enforce whatever other mandates
are in place so you would
likely every committee room would likely
have to have you know
their own security or sergeant or
someone to enforce these rules
it gets much more complicated when it's
just the 20 legislators
in the room i think we can
we can make sure that we're socially
distancing we can make sure
that that's being followed so i think
that's the reason why you don't open it
to the public you really would have to
really allow it for rep's hall
but at the same time that's there's only
one of those
so it's also difficult uh and then
it sounds like you're just saying that
the the committee that can be there is
kind of the upper limit for what could
how many people can safely be present in
person
no it's just it's math it's the room is
a certain size
and if a room is you know x amount of
square feet
and everyone needs to be six feet apart
you only can fit a certain amount of
people in said room uh
when it comes to a public hearing we
there's no
uh we don't want to limit attendance to
say all right we only allow 10 people
into public hearing
that would be inappropriate i know there
was a huge uproar last year it was a
senate hearing
um and they there was just not enough
room
in the room this is pre-covered but
there was people
waiting all in the in the lobby trying
to get in there to testify
it was never going to work out and that
wasn't to me that wasn't
fair to the members of the public that
showed up appeared and then couldn't get
in the room
so i would hate to see that happen to
anyone and i also don't want it to be a
situation where
oh the first eight people that showed up
at the lobbyists or
special whatever and then members of the
public sorry there's not enough room
i think also generally speaking
having if you were to have all those
people in the lob
it's not just our committee it's all the
other committees that are meeting that
day they're gonna have issues as well
so you don't if you if you have 30
people show up for our committee
meetings because we're gonna we might
have a lot of bills scheduled that day
and you have 30 people show up at
another committee and 30 you know
it can start to overflow relatively
quickly all of a sudden you can have a
lot
uh the place can be overflowing so
i think that's having just us in the
building
again not my preference but i think it
would it still works
thank you that makes a lot of sense i
think what you're saying is
if we had everyone testifying it
wouldn't be safe but
just having the committee present with
the um air filters and so forth probably
is safe enough to do and then my my last
question was and i saved them all up
sorry
um so you said earlier that you really
want us to
get along and i'm really excited about
that because i don't want all the stress
of
drama you know we have enough drama
already um everywhere else in the world
um and you said that if you have a
problem with something in another member
stun that you should bring up with them
and not bring it to social media
and i know kind of where you're speaking
from because i remember hearing
from you and representative welch about
how personally um you were impacted
after the whole um issue with the pearls
and that you know you had death threats
and
representative welch like shut off his
email
and it sounds like it was really it's
certainly not something i ever want to
experience
um and so i was wondering if your
issue with another member comes up when
we're in a public hearing or in an exec
session
where we're in the public's view
private conversations aren't really
possible or appropriate
would you want us to bring up our
concern about another member
to you in the public hearing or would
you want us to hold it until it's over
and and i'm and mentioning this in case
it's an issue of like behavior like if
someone's repeatedly doing something
that you think is inappropriate would
you bring it up to the chair
or would you want us to wait until it's
over
noting especially that now that we're
you know recorded and it's um
that it may be like bringing up an issue
with the chair during the hearing
would almost be the equivalent of
putting it on social media at this point
so that's kind of what i was curious
about and i'll mute myself and stop
asking questions now thank you
so thank you for your point what my
point is is that if
to any member of this committee now
whether you want to bring it up
privately after the committee hearing
or if you want to raise it during the
hearing
i think i will tell each member that
they're free to raise it during the
hearing
or they can we can discuss it with me
directly after the hearing
i don't have a problem if if anyone on
this committee feels that another member
is not
you know showing uh appropriate decorum
i feel that
i would hope that they would bring that
to my attention right away
or to representative welsh's attention
right away bring it to someone's
attention
because one of the issues i
you know brought up and it's not a
defense to anything that happened last
term
but no one on the committee raised any
concern to
the seven members that were wearing a
symbol no one said anything to us during
the hearing
uh no members of the committee said
anything to us uh the chairman didn't
say anything to us
no so all the people in charge of
decorum didn't say anything to us
yet you know things kind of went in
another direction now
i my point with that is if
someone said something during the
hearing and raised the issue of decorum
i would have respected that and i can
imagine other members of the community
would have as well
and i think that would have really
helped us all out now when it comes to
raising
other concerns my my my thought is
if you are willing to type something
on twitter or whatever social media
platform you're using
and publish it you're not you you're
allowed to do that
i myself you have there's no rule saying
you can't do that i would just hope
whatever it is you type
on your your tablet or your computer or
your phone
that you're willing to say that same
thing to the committee directly
and i would hope and it's just my
preference
that whether it's a positive or negative
comment
i would appreciate to hear it from you
directly rather than you know read about
it
on twitter or facebook i to me just it
means a lot more to hear it directly and
that's why i represented my comments
i referenced my conversation with
representative gathright that
i don't believe she ever published
anything about that on social media
but i think from me and representative
gatherette's relationship
on a professional level it actually
improved the law
and it means a lot to me to have these
good relationships with people on this
committee
that we can have these conversations uh
so
my recommendation is if people follow
the lead myself from representing
gathering
with us i thought that was a good thing
and represent gather if you disagree i
thought it was a good conversation to
and i thought it you know on a
professional level after that i thought
we could talk about anything
exactly and in the same way and
when you put something on social media
this is more general advice
i may post something and but then other
people may
take it much further in any direction
and just when you're talking about
members of this committee
there's a lot of and very important
issues we're going to have especially
involving
police reform and a lot of bills are
coming up
and i'm just saying that if we
create hurt feelings amongst ourselves
it's going to be much more difficult for
us to conduct
business so can i stop anyone doing
anything no is it against the rule for
you to do no
you're free to do what you want and and
i will respect that but all i'm saying
is i would prefer
and encourage people to bring it before
the committee directly
and i think that that would be a
healthier situation for all of us
and you should be able to voice your
concerns to anyone on the committee if
you're
upset how someone's conducting
themselves i don't see why it's a
problem
to address that to the committee
directly i think it's uh it's your right
and
something that's i think would be a good
practice and perhaps we'll uh
will be more uh we'll set the tone and
lead by example with that
representative newman yeah i would just
have a
quick recommendation for you as you go
ahead and discuss this
things with the leadership is that like
i said before
my main concern is the elimination of
any kind of virtual capability
for a legislator to participate and vote
so that would cover the kind of all
committee meetings
and i would just make note that there
are plenty of places
plenty of legislative bodies or or other
governmental bodies like the school
board in nashua
where in a meeting that's with the
limited number of people like this
and there could be and some individual
because of their circumstances or their
health or whatever
as long as the emergency order is in
effect they would
they just could not bring themselves for
their own
safety and the safety of their family
could would not attend an indoor meeting
as long as that was the thing
so you should also give you could also
give consideration to things like
you we have people in nashua that
um that participate in the school board
meeting on the telephone they can hear
everything that said
in their auto you know they take roll
calls by voice
and so they're able to participate i i
would hate to see
that type of virtual capability
prohibited
in anything that you guys decide but
that's something for you to consider
thank you representative newman um i i
see that
representative o'hearn has joined us
and i don't know if his microphone is
working but i
we did it representable heard we did
introduce all of ourselves to the
members of the committee
i know you're a returning member of the
committee but if you'd like an
opportunity to
introduce yourself and explain your
background to the members on the
committee
i will afford you that time well i will
make it short and sweet uh
i didn't get the notice i had was
working yesterday and i just
actually saw it this morning so i
apologize for
being late i'm sullivan
county three ward one
of claremont i speak my fourth term on
the
criminal justice committee and my
experience is
law enforcement for 31 years retired
and that's it
mr chairman i would just note that
representative conley i think is present
by zoom and by telephone
well representative connolly if you'd
like to say some words to the committee
introduce yourself
floor is yours
thank you mr chairman can you guys hear
me
are you guys able to hear me can someone
give me a thumbs up
yes we did we take it off speakerphone
we can hear your kids
troll in the background um so thank you
all i'm sorry for the audio issues
um casey connolly i'm in my third term i
represent
ward one in dover i'm moving over from
transportation
um i see representative true here
representative
fine knight both of whom were
excellent to work with in the last
committee and we'll bring a lot to this
one
um so i'll just i guess leave it at that
uh oh i was uh i worked as a news
reporter for a decade
i now write for a trade magazine for the
shipping industry
so that's it nice nice to see you all
happy to be in this committee thank you
thank you representative calling do any
any other of the
members of the committee have any other
questions or concerns they wish to
address at this time
we i do see a member of the public who
has their hand up
ms lepage yep that was a mistake
my apologies no questions
no that was my i accidentally clicked it
oh
all right
but i believe that covers everything
that we can cover for today
and i want to thank everyone obviously
for participating in the orientation
as more information comes available i'll
be sure to provide to everyone on the
committee
as you know as you guys all know things
are changing relatively
day by day so once i get more
information
i will be sure to let everyone know what
we're going to do and when we're going
to be meeting
if um i will say if you are the
prime sponsor or sponsor of any those
coming before the committee
and just again understand that
we may be sub we may not be able to have
the
luxury of the subcommittees so we may
want to retain
more of those bills than we would like
so just be prepared for that
um i want to thank everyone again and
there'd be no additional questions
uh we can adjourn the meeting for today
thank you bye-bye thanks everybody see
you
soon thank you see you soon